that's not the plan
it was a lot happening umizino left me
the voicemail I don't know if you
remember that but that was I don't what
you know what there's listen my brain is
so hip-hop fried at this point
please catch me up because I'm sure oh
gosh I mean we're skipping a lot but the
business we're gonna go back we're gonna
go back all right
the Benzino voicemail oh my gosh um yeah
so I had been I've been freelancing for
the source like here and there and I
think they owed me might have been like
eighteen hundred dollars or something
like that which again like I'm young
yeah that's I mean 1800 that's
definitely rent in a car note like this
you know sure a serious chunk of change
back especially back then yeah and so I
think it had been it had been maybe like
a year right and you know I had like
emailed the you know corporate office
nobody's responding and I think I I
didn't have the concept of what was
going on there at the time like they
were kind of falling apart so the house
was burning my little 1800 or whatever
it was was not really a priority but I I
ran into Dave somewhere in Miami and um
I mean shout out to Dave he you know I
respect what he did with the source and
um yeah and he's got a
for sure
yeah I mean I always have respect for
for Dave and what he accomplished with
the source um but I do think you know
there was like some missteps in the in
the later years but on this particular
occasion like I had run into him
somewhere in Miami and I think I was
feeling myself a little bit because they
they let me in the club before him like
we both were like yo you're in Miami
well I was at the time like that was
like my like everybody knew me you know
the doorman was always like okay I let
her in you know so they let me in right
they let us both in but they let me in
first and I was like oh okay you know
check us out yeah yeah
um but I and I was trying to be
respectful I was like you know hey is
there somebody I can contact corporate
like I've been trying to get this
invoice paid and nobody's got back yeah
okay and he was like he was like maybe
smoking weed or something he kind of he
just kind of blew me off like you know
just didn't really answer me went inside
and so I kind of I was like feeling some
kind of way and so
we did this year-end issue that was like
the year-end Awards I mean I mean we
might have even took that idea from The
Source I don't know but it was supposed
to be like humorous rewards we were
given to people so the time the talk
around the industry is about how Benzino
is extorting Dave yeah
Ryan's book and and you know heard I
think uh I don't know if Kim's book was
out yet but you know this this has been
out for a while I remember the work
there I've been talking about this so I
said something about Benzino extorting
Dave and then trying to be like a proper
journalist I said you know disclaimer
here they owe me money that's why I'm
talking [__] and
send it to print and when you do a
magazine I mean you write something and
by the time it actually reaches the
public it's
six weeks later at least so six weeks
later I'm just sitting at home at like
midnight and this number I don't know
calls me and it's like [__] you hangs up
and I'm like
okay
somebody calls back so Dave called me
the first time second call is Benzino
and you know it took me like a minute
honestly to even remember I'm like what
did I yeah yeah like what is this about
and then I'm like oh yeah I forgot about
that thing I wrote and so Benzino cussed
me out for like it was like a 90-minute
call like he just
he seems like yeah he seems like the
kind of guy he has a short time to
scream a lot for sure yeah because I've
seen I've seen the weight just unravels
online rather quickly with people so I'm
like scrambling running around the house
like I'm like I know I have a recorder
here somewhere like I gotta record this
you know he's just yeah going off well
it was kind of funny because it was like
very um like if you're gonna insult
somebody and hurt them there has to be
like a little kernel of Truth in it but
it was like very he was like you're just
a fat [__] and I I mean I weighed like
110 pounds or something I was like who
are you talking to he's like you you fat
blind [__] and you're like I don't wear
glasses it was just a lot of really
generic like stuff you might throw at a
female just you know I'm gonna send this
you know it's like he had like an
assault board for women yeah like Just
Darts at it and was like
you're a [__] but um I remember I was
on uh AOL Instant Messenger you know
everybody would yeah everybody was my
name and so I was I was on the computer
after this call and DJ Quest popped up
from from Fort Myers and we were just
talking I was like you won't believe
like what just happened to me he's still
there too right questions still in Fort
Myers yeah yeah shout out to Quest he
was always our our Fort Myers uh connect
but I was like you won't believe this
call I just got and he's he's like oh I
wish you had recorded that I put it on
my mixtape I'm like yeah I know and um
so I go to the office like a few days
later or whatever and check the
voicemail and he'd actually called there
first and left this voicemail so he
called me a [__] monkey which I don't
even know what that means I'm taking
that but uh Cyrus you slept monkey yeah
so I sent it to um I sent it to Quest
I'm like here you go put it on your
message put it on the mixtape he says it
to Tony Neal who had the coordinator DJ
still thinking Tony sends it too
everybody 200 DJs wow and Funk my next
thing I know like Funk Master Plex is
calling me we gotta get you on the air
to talk about this because I think they
have yeah yeah yeah yeah I feel like
everyone had a situation with Benzino in
a certain point in time yeah so it it um
it definitely made the rounds because I
remember not too long after that I went
overseas with uh with Trey Songz and we
were in like I want to say Denmark or
Sweden or something and I would always
bring magazines give it to the DJ so I
go up to the DJ booth and give the guy a
magazine he didn't even speak English
and he was like [__] monkey like you he
knew who I was so wow I wasn't mad about
it and then and we did kind of like
squash things at a certain point after
that so yeah I mean it is what it is but
it's a great story though